let's jump in
thanks for joining us for local
development techniques with kubernetes
here's the part where i tell you i am
definitely going to post the slides on
my site tonight
but in this talk there are no slides it
will only be live demos we're going to
look at a bunch of tools that will allow
us to work with containers rather than
assuming it's the downstream concern
that somebody else's problem
we're going to look at tools that will
help us in our local inner loop
all the tools that we'll look at is here
in this gist
and
yeah that url is really long so let's
head over to robrich.org and click on
presentations and here's local
development techniques with kubernetes
here at ndc sydney you can click on this
link and that will get you straight to
this gist really easily
while we're here at robrich.org
let's click on about me and we'll learn
some of the things that i've done
recently
i'm a cyril developer advocate if you're
struggling with your data mesh i would
love to learn from you i'm a microsoft
mvp a docker captain and a friend of red
gate
ac gift camp is really fun easy gift
camp brings volunteer developers
together with charities to build free
software
we start building software friday after
work sunday afternoon we deliver the
completed software to the charities
sleep is optional caffeine provided if
you're in phoenix
come join us for the next a-z give camp
or if you'd like a gift camp here in
sydney or wherever you're connecting
from hit me up on email or twitter and
let's get a gift camp in your
neighborhood to you
some of the other things that i've done
i do a lot of docker and kubernetes
training consulting if you have that
need i'd love to help
and one of the things i'm particularly
proud of i replied to a dot-net rocks
podcast episode they read my comment on
the air and they sent me a mug
so there's my claim to fame my
coveted.net rocksmug and if you'd like
it no i'm just kidding
yeah richard campbell is awesome
so let's dig in
now i have a bunch of things where we're
gonna look at ways to start containers
differently to be able to visualize
container contents visualize cluster
contents and finally debug inside of
containers
let's start in
i'm going to cd into 1
and
let's take a look at this inside of vs
code
i have this docker file here
and it references my server my node code
right here and i'm getting ready to
build it okay
so now i need to say docker build um i
need a dot for some reason let's tag it
oh wait the t doesn't go there it goes
over here hello
node v 0.1
once i've got that built now i need to
run it docker run
hello
node
v 0.1 do i need the dot no i don't i do
need to dash p oh wait that doesn't go
here it goes over here we're spending a
lot of time
thinking through the process of building
and running a container
instead
let's pop open this docker compose file
now this definitely is the simple one
just to kind of get a feel for what
we're going to do this docker compose
file allows us to capture all of the
build and run details here in one file
here's hello node here's the dot here's
the ports that we want to map oh i
completely forgot about setting that
environment variable
now when we're ready to go we can say
docker compose
up
and in this case because the container
doesn't exist yet it's automatically
going to
build that
image straight away and then it will
start the container
now i can just come up to localhost 3000
and so let's come to
localhost three
not that one
localhost 3000 and we can see the
website is running
now if you're familiar with docker
compose maybe this is old hat
let's hit ctrl c and let the website
come back down
but let me show you one trick that is
pretty interesting here
network mode of bridge
now by default when we start a docker
compose file it will start a separate
network now that's great in ensuring
that the containers that we start here
don't interact with the containers that
we start in a different file but what if
we have a docker compose file for our
back end and a docker compose file for
our data stores and we're debugging the
front end
well we want the back end and and the
container the storage to be able to
communicate together
so let's use network mode of bridge in
all of the places and now it won't
create a separate network and
the containers that we start in various
docker files will be able to communicate
with each other
that's perfect
so now we do a doc docker
compose down and all of the details
about running and starting are now so
solved in that docker compose file we
don't need to remember that we can
instead
focus on accomplishing the business
logic for our users
excellent docker desktop is a great uh
mechanism for being able to
run
both docker mode and kubernetes mode
we come in here to docker desktop we
turn on kubernetes mode and we have a
kubernetes environment
but what if we want to run
differently
let's talk about minicube minicube is an
alternate docker runtime that allows us
to run containers just as we would and
also gives us a kubernetes environment
as well
so i come in here and i'll say mini cube
start and i've already done that in this
case so we can see that we have this
virtual machine running with mini cube
already set up
now in this case i chose to run it on
hyper-v but if you're on a mac you can
run it on hyperkit and you can also run
it inside of wsl
now you'll notice that i also have other
virtual machines for other
kubernetes clusters that i wanted to run
if i wanted to run my link or d demo
i'll run it in this one and my istio
demo will run here now these clusters
won't collide because they're separate
spots
now one of the things that people often
ask me about is um
when i'm doing docker training is well
where are my volumes stored
and when you're running docker desktop
all i can say is
they're in
docker very specifically excludes us
from that so that we don't mess it up
but with minicube it's the internals
exposed batteries included version
so let's do this let's do mini cube ssh
now i'm inside that virtual machine
and the cool part about being inside
that virtual machine sudo su
cd var
lib
docker
um ls minus l when people ask me where
are the docker volumes now they're in
this folder and you can go now traverse
it and go wander through it you can also
app get install content this is the
battery's included internals exposed
version
now some of the niceties that docker
desktop gives us like automatically
proxying between localhost and the
virtual machine associated with docker
those things don't apply so if i want to
map volumes in i need to first create a
proxy between my local machine and a
particular folder inside that virtual
machine
and instead of connecting to localhost
i will connect to this ip address or
i'll just use the hostname of minicube
now that's great
now that i've got that environment set
up let's do a mini cube
docker env and i'll tell it my shell is
power shell there's an open bug that
allows it to
it automatically detects power shell and
command prompt and
terminal on mac but there is a bug that
doesn't allow it to yet detect
powershell core
so once i've set these environment
variables now i'm able to run all of my
standard docker commands like i did
before docker image list and we can see
the content
in a similar way i could open up a
command prompt and i could say dot mini
cube
docker env and it automatically creates
instead of powershell
environment variables it will create
windows command prompt environment
variables
or it will sit here blinking
there we go so i set these environment
variables
and now
docker image list and i can get at the
content here as well
now it is the
batteries included internals exposed
version so if i say docker container
list
by default inside docker desktop we have
this check box that allows us to turn
off the kubernetes containers
we can choose to turn it on to expose it
but in minicube it is exposed
automatically
so which containers did i launch well i
noticed that all of the kubernetes
control plane pods start with kds
underscore pods so i could say docker
container list and i will pipe it to
grep v
k8s
now i only list the containers that i
started and in this case i haven't
started any yet
that's perfect
so minicube is a great way to be able to
start containers differently
now docker desktop definitely is the
easy button and we get automatic network
proxying and all kinds of interesting
things there but minicube allows us to
do something a little bit different
minicube is great at running in nested
virtualization scenarios for example
where docker desktop just says hey
you're inside of a virtual machine i'm
not going to help
so if you're inside nested virtual
machines then you might consider running
inside minicube
once you've got it going you have an
identical docker and kubernetes
environment just like you did with
docker desktop
next up let's take a look at
docker watch
now i would really love to be able to
say docker watch and have it
automatically rebuild my image any any
time uh something happens well that
isn't a
command
but let's take a look at scaffold
now scaffold is an open source project
that allows us to automatically rebuild
our image optionally push it to a
container registry and start up our
content inside of kubernetes
anytime code changes
so we'll start with a scaffold init and
that will get us this yaml file that
describes the details
now here i have this
scaffold yaml file
it has an image note that it doesn't
have a version number because as
scaffold notices concern
changes it will automatically rebuild
that content so i don't want to specify
a version number here
but then here is my kubernetes yaml file
that will automatically start and it
just includes the normal content
deployment
service
and
in this case i didn't need an ingress
but here i do have a version number and
scaffold will override that nicely
i have a docker file that does all the
things so let's start up scaffold
scaffold dev
and now it's watching my content
so um
as it boots up
it will automatically notice that i've
got some content it will go rebuild my
image that's perfect and it will start
to push that into place
now because it's running in kubernetes
cube ctl get all let's take a look at
what port it chose there's that port so
we'll head off to
we're running mini cube so instead of
localhost we'll use minicube and we'll
go to that port number and now we see
our website hello world
great
so now let's come in here and let's
change the content instead of hello
world let's say hello ndc
sydney
i'm going to
um
i'm going to push save here
and we can see that it automatically
starts rebuilding my image that's
perfect
now optionally it can push it to a
container registry and then it will
reapply my kubernetes yaml file with the
new image in place
i'm going to do a kubernetes get all
again and we can see this one
terminating and this one's starting if i
hurry i can
catch it in the act but let's push
refresh and um
let's give it a second since i'm screen
sharing and all the things then
sometimes it takes a minute
let's see if it will come back down
and then we'll refresh our web page and
now we get the new content perfect
now i didn't need to do anything i just
pushed save in my code editor and
automatically the new content popped
into place now i did need to push
refresh in my browser maybe if i had an
auto refresh in my browser that might be
really interesting
but scaffold is a really great way then
to be able to automatically rebuild my
container anytime something happens
now it's not uncommon where i'm like
yeah but but it's just not building
correctly and that's where scaffold will
be perfect
let's hit ctrl c and now scaffold is
down
next up let's take a look at being able
to visualize content inside of a
container
now we've been working with the hello
node cont image so let's say docker
history
hello node
and we can see all of the commands that
were used to build up this image
all the way back from the node base
image that i started building on all the
way through all the content that i built
and we can take a look at the sizes of
the various layers but what content is
in that layer did i build it correctly
am i in the right directory
that's where docker history really can't
help us but let's take a look at dive
now dive is a really elegant program
that allows open source here up on
github that allows us to be able to
visualize the contents of our cluster
we can cruise up and down through the
layers we can see the files that are
created in each layer
so let's say dive hello node v0.1
and by default it will try and pull it
from docker in this case it already
exists so it can pull it up just fine
i'm going to push tab and then hit space
bar to close some of these folders let's
close this folder and this folder and
this folder okay tab back to my list of
layers and this is the original layer
next in this layer the next layer will
add the home and node directories the
next layer pulls in some yarn content
that's pretty cool the next layer adds
some stuff i think it's
down here yep the user directory
and
let's come up to the top here
and here's where my docker file began i
created this app directory one more
layer down and we can see that we
populated the app directory
now in this case we have our server.js
as we expect but we also have a docker
compose and a dockerfile
that's not really what i want it looks
like i have a mistake in my code i'm
going to come back here into my folder
and i'm going to create a new file that
is a
docker ignore file
now in my docker ignore file i want to
specify all of the content i want to
ignore libraries that i download so the
node modules folder i want to ignore
built content so in a net project i
would have bin and obj in this case i
don't have any built content that i want
to ignore the dist folder is often in a
node project
i also have user specific content that i
might want to ignore
star.user the vs folder maybe the dot vs
code folder the dot idea folder
i also have log files and other content
so star.log
but in this case i really wanted to
ignore this docker file and docker
compose file so docker compose.yaml
docker file i might also choose to
ignore the dot git folder
once i've built up this dot docker
ignore file then if i was still running
scaffold scaffold would automatically
rebuild my image and now i wouldn't have
that content in my container
dive is really elegant at being able to
see the contents of the files in the
container did i put them in the wrong
directory is that why my container isn't
starting up correctly or did i include
more content that i needed maybe my node
modules folder is really full or i have
a step that copies in some libraries and
then changes them and so both layers are
really big that's really powerful to be
able to visualize the contents of my
container
i'm going to hit ctrl c and i jump back
out of dive
so dive was great to be able to
visualize the contents of a container
next let's look at visualizing the
contents of a cluster now we can look
both at the docker mode of things and we
can also look at the kubernetes mode of
things let's first look at docker mode
i'm going to start up
let's take a look at
lazydocker
now lazydocker is an open source github
project that allows us to be able to
visualize a docker
cluster
now you can see them clicking around in
this screen if you're using a mac or if
you're using windows terminal or
powershell you can definitely click
through
if you're using a windows command prompt
you'll need to use the
the key bindings to be able to navigate
so let's start up lazydocker lazydocker
and
we'll be able to visualize the contents
of this cluster
so
i'm going to click on the stats and
let's cruise through to a container
that's running
i love these graphs of being able to
visualize the content within the cluster
you know ascii art to be able to do this
if all if you only have ssh access into
your cluster then this can be a great
way to be able to see the content let's
take a look at the images here's the
image and the various tags associated
with it yep that's the one that
scaffold built for us here's the one
that we built from docker
compose and we can cruise through the
other ones
here's our node base image that we
started from that's pretty cool
so
lazydocker is a great way to be able to
visualize the docker side of things from
a command prompt let's also visualize
the content using a ui
next up let's take a look at portinger
now partainer allows us to be able to
visualize the docker side of things
partiner also has mechanisms for
visualizing the kubernetes side but it's
not quite as strong
so i went to
the
um
the docs inside of partainer and grab
this docker compose file
docker compose up
let's take a look at that docker compose
file
here's that docker compose file for
partainer and we're binding to port 9000
and so
let's go to
a mini cube
and take a look at portainer now our
first step is to log in we haven't set a
password yet so
let's build ourselves a password
and now we're running
now we could definitely connect to a
cloud-based cluster perhaps on azure or
aws or gcp
we could also put a an agent inside of
our on-prem cluster
we could connect to a remote docker
environment but in this case let's
connect to the docker environment that
we're currently running
now it does say that we need to map the
docker socket into place now
pardon me we'll want to do that
carefully because the docker socket
allows us to make changes inside of our
cluster
but here in that docker compose file we
can see that we've already got that
docker socket mapped into place that's
perfect
we have a second volume that will save
our password details so
if we log back in we'll know that we'll
we're hitting the correct account
so now that we've got that docker socket
mapped let's connect
and let's dig into our local cluster
we can see the images that we've pulled
and yep i've got a few um here's the
hello node version uh 0.1 that we
created
we can take a look at volumes i always
like wandering through here and noticing
the things that i forgot to delete
um
like this one
um we can also take a look at running
containers now we see the partainer
container that's running right now and
we can also add a new container
let's go look for hello oh i love that
intellisense let's go grab hello node v
0.1 we can choose to expose all the
ports or in this case i'm going to
choose to
grab a port specifically 3000 to port
3000 we can also set volumes and
environment variables and other details
that we want in this container and then
once we've got it ready to go let's
deploy the container and now we can see
that container running inside of our
cluster
there's the hello node image that it
used and we've got this container name
now that's great digging into this
container we can take a look at some of
the details associated with it here's
the logs the console logs and it says
it's running on port 3000 so if we come
here to mini cube 3000 we can see that
container is running
oh
and apparently i'm not getting that text
that's interesting
um
we can also take a look at other details
inspect is great if ever you've done a
docker inspect and you have just a wall
of config i kind of like being able to
open and close these details one of the
things i like to look at is the networks
in this case it's got an ip address of
172.17.0.4
that's kind of nice
and wandering through the ports it's
nice to be able to scroll up and down
and to be able to look at that content
now we were able to take a look at the
configuration details we can also take a
look at the console
now this is an alpine based image so
instead of bash i'm going to switch to
ash and i'm going to connect
if the only way that you can connect to
your cluster is through a web browser
you can still
get into your container now i'm running
on windows but this is inside my
container so dur isn't a thing but i can
do an ls minus la and we can see that
content yep
i haven't rebuilt that container since
we adjusted the
docker ignore file
and now i can say node
server.js and of course that port is
already in use by the process that's
doing that let's do ps minus ef and we
can see the original node process
running inside of our container
now this could be
really helpful if for example we want to
say
did we start in the wrong folder did we
copy the content into the wrong folder
um is our configuration not quite right
we do want to avoid changing our
container contents this is not the way
to do last mile configuration
but we can take a look at our container
and validate that our container is
running as expected
once i'm done i'm going to exit out of
here and i'm back to my web browser
now we started a container on a cluster
and so you do want to secure your
partainer dashboard very carefully
once we're done let's remove this
container we could automatically remove
persistent volumes let's do that
and now our um
and now we've stopped that curt
container let's hit ctrl c
docker compose down and um
we'll take down portainer
docker volume prune
yep
i had a few too many volumes kicking
around
and partainer was great at being able to
show that
so we got to look at the docker side of
things now let's take a look at the
kubernetes side of things now kubernetes
is going to launch the containers but it
wraps them in this nice mechanism of
pods
so let's start out by looking at this
from the command line
um let's look at
uh
here's portainer let's look at k9s
now k9s is our canines is an open source
project here that allows us to be able
to visualize the kubernetes cluster now
it does look a lot like
vi work a lot like vi so when we start
canines
then we'll use our familiar vise
syntax so i'm going to hit colon and
i'll switch to namespaces
now in my namespaces i can cruise up and
down let's dig into the ingress nginx
one we can see two pods have finished
and one pot is running i'm going to dig
into that we can see the one container
there let's dig into that container we
can take a look at logs
in this case the logs are pretty empty
so i'll back back out
let's take a look at yep there's the
empty logs and we can walk our way back
out
i'm gonna hit
colon again and exit
and nope that's not the command
control c dumps us back out of canines
now that was a great way to be able to
visualize the kubernetes side of things
i like to switch back and forth between
lazy docker and canines depending on the
type of visualization that i want to see
if you only have ssh accessed into your
cluster then these can be excellent
tools
next let's take a look at a ui way of
doing this
and i'm going to showcase schooner
now schooner is a free and open source
project kubernetes does come with a
dashboard but authentication is not part
of
the kubernetes dashboard by default
by comparison schooner has
authentication turned on by default so
let's start
the kubernetes dashboard
i'll say cube ctl apply
schooner nope dash f schooner
and up starts the schooner dashboard
cube ctl get all let's see what port we
got chosen yep 32 000 and let's head off
to
minicube colon
32 000
and take a look at our schooner
dashboard
now by default we are asked to log in so
let's go grab the authentication token
it's stored as a secret inside of our
cluster
and paste that here
now i love being able to visualize my
kubernetes cluster this way let's take a
look at the namespaces and the various
content in each namespace so here's the
pod that's running and the two pods that
have finished we can dig into a
particular pod and be able to explore
its configuration
i like to come in here and take a look
at storage
and volumes because it's really easy for
us to accidentally forget volumes and
maybe have them kick around for a long
time
another thing i love to look at here
inside accounts i like to look at
secrets
now we're in the default namespace let's
switch to all namespaces and we can see
that
there are a lot
if you find a lot of secrets and you
find that they're really old it might be
time to rotate some of those secrets
now i'm going to switch to just the
default namespace and we'll take a look
at the schooner token that we have right
here
now this is the token that i used to
authenticate
if you have access to the cluster enough
to be able to see the secret then you
have access enough to be able to
visualize it with schooner
my cluster is running locally so i don't
mind showing you this token but that's
the token that i copied and pasted into
place to be able to log into schooner
but i can also look at other secrets in
here as well and that's really helpful
i uh once we've visualized our content
inside of schooner i'm going to come in
here to my profile and i will choose to
log out
now schooner
makes me log in by default the built-in
kubernetes dashboard does not it's
really easy to accidentally flip it from
a cluster ip to a node port and
accidentally expose it externally
much like a portainer we could do
some we could create content inside of
our kubernetes cluster and so we really
want to secure these dashboards
carefully
let's take down schooner cube ctl delete
dash f
schooner
and now schooner is not running as well
next let's take a look at debugging
inside of our cluster
now i have this extra folder here called
debugging i'm going to open that in a
separate
vs code in a moment let's take a look at
how that'll work
now when we're debugging inside a mini
cube
we are debugging inside of vs code vs
code will actually split in half
now there's half of it that's running
inside of our ui that allows us to do
theme extensions like our font choice
and our color palette
the other half of vs code is running as
a server and that's where our language
extensions and our build and compile
mechanisms work
now as port connects those together and
we have a volume mount that allows us to
get the code into the container
now that we've got vs code split in half
we can
work on our code locally and be able to
get advantage of content that we may not
have installed on our local machine
now the first step is to
come in here to extensions and go look
for the remote extension
now
here's the remote containers extension
which very specifically powers
containers but there's also a remote
development extension that includes both
the remote containers extension and the
remote wsl extension and a remote ssh
extension
if you only have ssh access to your
raspberry pi and you want to do some
debugging on that yeah you can keep
sshing in and maybe using vi or copying
content to and fro but you can also
create a vs code mechanism where you run
that server on the pi and you're able to
debug that content from vs code locally
so i've got the remote development
extension installed that gives me all
three of these
extensions and with that installed i now
have this green button down here on the
bottom right
i'll click on this green button and up
pops this menu of being able to do
really cool things here's the content
inside wsl inside ssh but we'll focus on
the container content
let's start by trying a development
container sample now we're able to pick
various technologies and once we pick
that it will automatically spin up a
container with that content ready to go
i didn't need to install this content if
i wanted to play with python or with
rust and i didn't want to install those
compilers or maybe i want to go try some
java stuff will my content work if i
upgrade to java 11 or java 13
i don't know let's run that in a
container where we don't have any
conflicts
when we get ready to install this in our
local content let's pop this open again
and we can say add development container
configuration files
this allows us to automatically scaffold
content in our language of choice to be
able to put the content necessary for
starting up our our system
now uh
i've already got this content installed
let's open it up inside of our
second vs code and we'll be able to
start debugging this content
now i have a dot dev container folder
and inside that i have a
devcontainer.json file and that's the
content that we need for vs code to
recognize that this is debuggable inside
of a container
once it starts up
in a second as it activates all of its
extensions it will pop up a dialog that
says hey can i restart this inside of a
container
um
yes
please reopen that inside of a container
i also could have definitely come in
here and clicked the box and said yes i
would like to reopen it a container but
it doing it automatically is actually
really helpful
i love watching these logs pop up
because it's really fun to see how it
builds up the container maps the volume
into place and automatically gets that
set up for us it will take just a second
grabbing the
local
content
it looks like it gave it a name that's
great
and it looks like we've got our
container up almost running
mapping that volume into place
starting the extensions
and now i'm running
perfect
now this is running inside of a
container i'm here on windows but if i
create a new terminal
i've got oh not that one
let's start a new terminal
you name minus a i can tell that this is
really inside the container this is
linux if i come back to my command
prompt and i say docker container list
and we'll use our trick to get rid of
all of the
kubernetes control plane
here is that container oh docker
container list
helps if i spell container correctly
here's that container that it just spun
up
now that's excellent let's close this
and we'll take a look at the dot dev
container dev container json file
now our first step inside the dev
container json file is either to specify
an image or a docker file
now this docker file is not the docker
file that we'll use to get into
production but rather the docker file
that we used to be able to set up our
debugging container
so i have that here inside the dev
container folder as well
now you'll notice that we're not doing
any copies we're not doing any volume
mounts we're not starting anything with
cmd this is just creating the
environment that vs code can use to be
able to set up our environment now in
this case i used node alpine and i
specified the workspace directory i also
installed git and curl in case i wanted
to do any source control
actions here inside the container
now that we've got our
image or our docker file then we have a
post create command now i wanted to npm
install inside the container now i
didn't want the windows versions of any
native modules i wanted the linux
versions of it so after the container
starts up it will do an npm install to
be able to get all my dependencies
now i can specify various settings that
i want do i want to include various
extensions installed inside the server
side of this in this case i just chose
big font sizes
we can also list the forwarded ports
vs code is really good at discovering
when we launch ports but in this case
i'm going to very specifically call out
that my port is 3000 and it will
automatically proxy it back to my
machine so it won't be mini cube 3000
but rather localhost 3000 that means if
we're using this technique inside of
azure or inside of aws then we won't be
hitting
an aws url rather we'll be hitting
localhost to be able to tunnel through
into our debugged container now i am
running inside a mini cube so i do have
to specify the workspace mount and i
have to specify that i'm mapping this
folder from my pc into that vm and then
map it from that vm
into the container
now that we've got that content in place
let's start debugging our system i'm
going to create a breakpoint here and a
breakpoint here and just like i would in
any
environment i've got my dot vs code
folder and so i can start debugging
now the cool part about this we see that
we've got syntax highlighting we've got
a normal type of run environment yep we
hit our break point straight away oh
would you like to open it in a browser
why yes i would
notice that it's localhost 3000. we're
proxying from the vs code through that
socket into the remote container
now we're still at our break point so we
can
i'm going to take off this break point
and push play
and now we'll get to our first break
point in our code let's take a look at
the request
much like we would if we were debugging
anywhere we can wander through the
variables that we have set here is the
url and in this case it's a forward
slash excellent
now i can take a look at various
variables i can step into with f10 step
over with f11 or no step into with f11
step over with f10
and do all the debugging that i need to
i'll push play and the next request
we'll see will not be the slash but this
one rather will be
looking for the favicon.ico
so yep we're looking for faveikon.ico
and i'm able to debug my website
in the ways that i need to i'll take off
this breakpoint and just push play and
we can see the content pull up inside of
our container
now
the cool part is it is just regular vs
code
and so i can do regular intellisense and
um
content here but we do have vs codes
split in two pieces one is running on my
local machine to be able to give me the
colorization font choices the other part
is running inside the container that
gives me that syntax highlighting and
debugging experience
once i'm done here inside the container
i'm going to come into this green spot
and i'm going to say close remote
connection and it pushes
vs code back into normal mode where it
joins those two pieces and i could open
up a different project
now this has been really cool being able
to visualize content inside of a
container visualize clusters in
interesting ways to be able to visualize
to be able to debug inside of a
container and also to be able to start
containers easier
you can take a look at all of the tools
that we've seen here on this gist and
grab this just really easily from
robrich.org or i'll put a link here in
chat
if you're watching this video later hit
me up on twitter at rob underscore rich
i'd love to learn about the tools that
you really enjoy and how i can
incorporate them in this talk as well
for those of you here live at the event
one of the questions i often get here is
well does this work in my cluster what
if i'm on aws or openshift
all the tools that we looked at today
are very specific to docker and
kubernetes and will work on any flavor
of docker and kubernetes you can use
mini cube to debug locally or you can
use canines to be able to visualize your
openshift cluster
you can use a docker
lazydocker to be able to visualize both
your local docker desktop environment or
maybe a docker
swarm instance
none of these tools are specific to or
barred from any particular cloud vendor
one of the tools that i wish i had time
to explore is helm and i i actually
originally included helm in this talk
but
helm grew out of it and so i have now a
completely separate talk that discusses
how wonderful helm is at templating
content if you get tired of all the
duplication inside of your kubernetes
yaml files then helm could be a great
choice at removing that duplication well
this has been a lot of fun getting to
show you local development techniques
with kubernetes grab me on twitter at
rob underscore rich if you find some
concerns maybe later today or if you're
pondering on this tomorrow or next week
thanks for joining us today